Ah ah
ah I can't help being pulled a little different Let's get along with this as an opportunity
Small wings of a type cutter
I'm a performer You guys I'm Noel This muscle box is a dish of kappa If the interest rate is stupid
a  Noel's muscular
stupid papaster It's a mysterious name, it's a spare in it, it's
obviously a stupid nickname, it was there, it was
like a pasta shop What was it here
?  I understand that, but what's the
special training? I like to sing in this place.
Come on, I'm dreaming. I'll
dance
.
It's a part of a big machine. It's a
boom in 5th place.
Yeah, that's right.
Idols are singing, dancing, and performa
.  I wonder if money is lucky, but it's
not just an obstacle. It's important if the wall isn't an obstacle.
You don't know because you've never had a problem with money, but money is important.
If you don't have what you drew, you should eat steak ah
ah ah ah